my other computer so I can yeah you read
the chat okay
I think we are ago can you check to see
if it's ready okay I'm gonna check I
don't see it in my subs but let me go to
your channel okay
Godzilla Mentos should really subscribe
to you yeah you should probably do that
no I'm not quarantine yeah we are live
oh sweet 46 people watching already it's
been like two seconds looking stylish my
friends okay yeah you gotta appreciate
the glass the shower and my hair looks
all shitty and what because I'm bad at
calming it and also it's way too long no
they got the face cams yeah except
mine's kind of cut off but whatever that
we can see most of you I think probably
well we can see about half of me really
I'm not I'm right it's fine
yeah you can switch back and forth I
think you can do that yeah I was just
switching back and forth based on who's
the primary conversation person in that
particular moment
what's everyone saying kind of cut off
my like kinda gay sorry your hair long
growing a beard like David that's to be
expected well David's gonna be Ryker
yeah I'm growing a beard because I'm
gonna be dressing up as commander Riker
for Halloween so I have to have beard
he's doing such a good job with the
beard I'm proud of him you see the the
glasses are uh when when the stream
roasts us we'll be able to hide the fact
that we're crying behind the glasses
like you ever see like like a celebrity
roast where they always have like really
fixed sunglasses on to hide their tears
it's like that exactly it's like that
David is gross thank you
I've always wanted to be called gross by
some random person on the internet that
that's really what I wanted out of today
what
your pinion on spider-man homecoming
we've talked a lot about spider-man
homecoming and I don't think we have
anything new to say at this point we've
baby done like six podcasts just talking
about spider-man homecoming go back yes
[Music]
I think we're gonna move away from
questions and we're gonna we're gonna
have a little bit of a conversation so I
so um so I I texted you a couple of days
ago Xavier that we said that I saw a
grand Budapest hotel and you said that
at school film Penn's talked about it so
tell me but roll at Film School is just
like absolutely in love with that movie
because grand Budapest hotel that to be
clear that's what it is
yeah and they talk about it a lot
basically in every class they have
something to say about it whether it be
about the editing or the script writing
or just the general production and as a
whole like they talk about the the way
the script was written and refer to it
as like line feeding where it's like
really quick back and forth so I think
mm hm and there's apparently some really
nice editing that's kind of fast-paced
in it that yeah there was a really great
editing unit my post teacher talks about
that a lot but I've never seen it I just
know that a lot of people tell me it's
great it's a good movie I saw it like a
couple days ago it's good it's funny cuz
beef soda can as gently as possible so
it doesn't just go next to the
microphone and piss everyone off it's
kind of hilarious because everybody
talks about it of this great movie but I
thought it was very literary it felt
like a book like a good old book like
from the 19th century movies that are
like there's there's certain movies that
you can really tell or based on a novel
just because there's it's that inspired
by the works of an Austrian writer from
the 1930s
Stefan's by Stefano but yeah that's
whether that was just been on my mind
it's the name of one of the characters
and evolve into that game it's people
with him yeah
I I'm really happy with how evil within
came out I got it recently it's really
good that's been like the first time
we're in like I don't know a couple of
months where I was like hey a game
announced at e3 I want to play that and
it comes out and I play it and it
doesn't disappoint the hell out of me
like I think that's very rare the other
time that happened was Resident Evil 7
so we've we've got 2 for this year 2
games that made Xavier really really
happy now this year was a pretty decent
year for movies as well I mean we got
babby driver which you haven't seen yet
we got Blade Runner which is probably
like which I haven't seen you ever del I
loved it so I haven't seen Blade Runner
and you haven't seen badly driver but we
both saw Logan and that was good
Logan is fantastic that's absolutely
like oscar-worthy Patrick Stewart needs
to win some kind of award yeah I agree
with that and it's kind of blockers that
he hasn't yet mm-hmm like what the hell
why of all people as Patrick Stewart not
won an award yeah Patrick Stewart needs
to have an awards what do I think of the
wines what do I think of the Wolfenstein
controversy Wolfenstein controversy
people don't like that people people are
people are offended that Wolfenstein is
saying that Nazis are bad which
shouldn't be a thing that people are
offended about okay like of all the
things that we are not agreed on it's
that Nazis are bad well hold on maybe
just hear them out they do they have a
point the dumbest thing you I there's no
excuse that's why the dumbest
controversies on the internet it is it's
it's mm-hmm like I people refer to
getting offended by everything as
outrage culture and it was like one of
the biggest examples of that in the past
like three years I mean they're there of
course there are people who are like
Black Panther doesn't have enough actual
African actors they're all just
african-americans it's not culturally
accurate like that's stupid that's a
dumb thing to complain about
and then there's well you know I didn't
know that Bethesda and its software were
a bunch of sjw's for for for killing for
a game about killing Nazis game about
killing cyborg Nazis another and I've
got another topic on that in terms of
people being stupidly pissed off did you
hear that there's a big controversy
about Oh or controversy would be better
at way of saying it is that about a
Disney Channel TV show having a game
character about that I mean if you don't
like it don't watch it that's all you
need to say about it you're offended
that it's a Disney Channel show because
as we know since the 2010s you know
started those those have taken a dip in
quality I'll have you know you know we
used to have classics like The Suite
Life of Zack and Cody and and everyone's
favorite anime Cory in the house oh and
by the way random person on the stream
we are not using Skype or using Google
Hangouts it's slightly less shitty and
actually works with our microphones yeah
it does
especially David's has had some problems
yeah mine is super fancy so here's the
thing like somebody could say good
comment in the stream is it a
Nickelodeon not a gay character and no
one batted an eye and that's because
that like Disney has this sort of weird
thing where there's but where people
sort of think of them as like this as a
role model which you're supposed to
model yourself after this for some dumb
reason so when when Disney has a gay
character
oh no that Disney is pushing the gay
agenda but when a movie about a gay
black guy wins Best Picture nobody cares
because that's not the soul of America
one of those things I mean he isn't
Disney kind of like associated with
anti-semitism because of what Walt was
was into back in the yeah yep
did Walt believe I think I don't
remember if he believed I don't know I I
never really took the time to go like
research into that and find out exactly
why ever all and says Walt Disney was
basically a crazy
Hitler loving psycho they they've
they've got accusing they've get it he
was really exaggerated the extent he did
have some weird views I can look I'm not
gonna look it up cuz I don't care and he
looked like Tom Hanks yeah and anybody
who looks like Tom Hanks is
automatically terrible except for Tom
Hanks he's amazing oh yeah Tom Hanks see
he's great the burbs is an amazing film
it's it's about a quiet suburban
neighborhood where a guy starts to
suspect that his neighbors have killed
and buried someone in their backyard and
every time he tries to rally his other
neighbors to go find proof and get them
in trouble something crazy always
happens and they always go damn we
couldn't get him this time you know also
hey I have not seen any of the Toy Story
movies you haven't seen any Toy Story
movies no not a single one with you
what's the deal why but still know what
ha ha that's dumb
you should watch those or at least the
first two the third ones going what what
how dare you say no they're saying how
dare me not see Toy Story that's one of
those like great American classics you
got to see them I mean you can watch the
first two the third one's kind of like
plot y is an exact duplicate of the
second one
and I mean it's still good it has its
own merit and a lot of funny scenes but
I think III was happier with the the way
the story ended at the second one but I
know a lot of people like the closure of
the third one just because it ends on a
really really neat scene but but yes
definitely look at those those are great
movies you wanna read some more sonic
high school know so you know so that was
that was a lot of fun don't want to read
more sonic high school you son of a
[ __ ] it gets really weird did you skip
it yes I'm read ahead it gets really
weird I read in my chapter sixteen
graphically describing the the
penetration it gets weirder than that
how what does sonic uses SuperSpeed in
the bedroom
no sonic did isn't in any of the sex
scenes but he does but let's just say
that Knuckles becomes a baby wait what
yes what he becomes a baby no that's
dumb he becomes a baby what else weird
happens knuckles and espyo fight each
other and then they ended up by fear and
then they and then they start furiously
making out and then knuckles flies into
the sky with the spit connecting him to
knuckles his mouth knuckle and then he
becomes convinced the knuckles mouth no
no spo2 knuckles and then knuckles flies
into rouges mouth and then pops out of
her butt as baby
what I refused to believe this is a real
thing that someone spent several years
writing that they spent several months
it was written all in 2012 how the [ __ ]
did they write that much in well I mean
did you see how long it was was it like
yeah it's it's it's um 36 K words okay
26 chapters how long are the Lord of the
Rings books by comparison well I was
comparing Lord of the Rings to another
fanfiction not this one okay
thanks for the guy from England for
watchin even though it's really late
over there we appreciate you showing up
we tried to make sure it'd be in like
the middle of the day for our folks in
the US and Canada but we apologize to
everyone overseas who has to watch this
at like 2:00 a.m. but streaming the
archives so you can check it out there
so do you want me to read the sex scene
this is chapter 6 no I don't a spear
whooshes house SP I walked to rouges
house it was time for the day before we
get into the graphic sex scene okay okay
this broadcast brought to you by the
fine folks at tea blocks tea blocks is
an affordable subscription-based service
that delivers custom t-shirts straight
to your doorstep with license start from
Marvel DC Disney Star Wars Naruto Game
of Thrones Breaking Bad and a whole lot
more you can get 10% off your first
order with the special promo code
Godzilla tbx which you can find in the
description go get some cool t-shirts
boys and girls all right yeah remember
there's a yeah remember the vid
sponsored so going by the t-shirt yeah
yeah walked to rouges house because it
was time for their date together and all
SPO could think about was that they were
about to make sex for their first time
Espio looked at the computer and read
about what to do and what the right
words were so you could know how it
works and how to say
right so no one would make fun of him it
was rouges house he was at now and it
was in front of him SPO knocked over his
house door I hope she is home said Espio
and she was she opened the door just
then hello I'm home said Rouge looking
always sexy in her tiny baby bra and
cool big cool boobs SPO thought she
looked like the hottest woman in the
world that he could see from here so
it's the hottest woman in the world that
I can see right now now there's other
ones out there but I can seek this one
right now yeah okay so maybe there's
like another girl walking down the
street who's who's not as hot
that's his frame of reference it's like
hottest girl in the world that I can see
currently cuz that one's not so bud but
this one this one really really doing it
for me right now where are you taking me
on our date tonight
whispered Rouge in a sext filled voice
SPO had thought this one over on the way
over so that he could say it right the
first time and get her to do what he
wanted that sex
well since vo just let me put on this
side sex look shocked people attack
locks are gonna watch this and fire me
Roo's looks shocked but she could
probably was excited to SPO could tell
they both have an arresting this they
both have directions
so what's that say about her Anatomy SPO
and Rouge both having erections what
what said ruies in the chocolate right
here one of the lines I guess yes this
hat made was made by tails pacifically
for our date pacifically not
specifically pacifically it makes a vm
it makes it impossible to see and
impossible to hear while i'm wearing it
SPO did a cool face it heard because
being smart can be cool as long as
you're not a nerd ass who you said okay
let's go inside
gently grabbed SVS hand but he pulled it
back and she fell causing him to fell
and they both fell onto the grass where
they rolled around in it until they were
about in the middle of ridges house lawn
so there was plenty of room around them
for activities no said Espio I want to
make sex in you right here that's hot
I want to make sexy right here I want to
make deep angry sonic based sex do you
think sonic ever uses any of your rings
there's a reason they're called traps
and David fell right into it that's the
story
no erections okay what's this summons
the chat saying I kind of want to hear
what they have to say we've been
neglecting them a little I'm not gonna
repeat that on the stream I will are you
kiddin are you okay are you having a
stroke
no I'm having a lot of fun Oh David
David Joey just messaged me he said I
just left the stream let me know when
David is done with sonic fanfics and
must be an SPO put on the invisibility
hat so nobody could see or hear them and
a whole new world of possibilities were
optioned to them so they could do sex in
whatever way they wanted and it was time
to start sex right now listen to this
come on come over here listen to this I
was looking at the chat on my phone
Espio revealed his penis to Rouge who
looked at it we said cool and took out
her vagina I don't think you how do you
take take out that's not how it works
this feels penis was really big from
looking at Rouge like when he is in
church and it's so boring you but you
just get a boner anyway you're just a
fight daredevil versus arrow probably
daredevil because he has an advantage
and he could probably catch arrows
cancer but hey come on you use vagina
look like a surprises here what
hey come on stop it I need to listen
listen to this line listen listen listen
Regina looked like a surprised ghost
SPOs penis approached Drew's like to fly
a plane flying down at the airport but
instead of being to a businessman it was
full of SPO screaming Italians no they
will not mute me they can't stop me with
that now moving on to the next topic
let's take a look at the the chat here
I'm just going to say that somehow sex
for this involved putting his penis in
her bellybutton
okay someone asked what I thought was
the best movie of the year
I don't know I really like Blade Runner
2049 I know that it's just falling the
[ __ ] apart no one watched it it'll never
get a sequel
well everyone said about the original
one well the Blade Runner and Blade well
Blade Runner I kind of saw that one
coming
because let's be honest Blade Runner is
the movie that nobody nobody's seen but
everybody says they want so let's say so
who's really surprised that with the
sequel everybody says they want to see
it but nobody sees it there you go
I mean you know when you have like
understated action scenes like the
action scenes are cool but they're kind
of they're spaced out a lot so it's not
like a Michael Bay movie where it's just
like one set piece exploding and then
the next one exploding and then you just
kind of get like tired no they try to
pace it out to the
action scenes or while they're cool
they're great they're very short and
succinct and you go wow that was awesome
I hope we get to see another one the the
acting is very solid because the I think
the script writing is very solid
I think that'll some of the the subtext
was a little on the nose like certain
certain characters motivations kept
getting kind of literally spelled out
for you by an advertisement on on a
billboard and they could have probably
reeled it back a little with that it's
seaman time all I'm saying is that this
this explains you need a sequel no but
they set themselves up for one and it
would be like this really really giant
epic universe sweeping movie if they did
like like it would be like the really
amazing giant third installment like
they took the the first one was a
relatively simple down-to-earth story
about one guy just running around
killing a bunch of rogue robots
the second one kind of tried to blow
that to a bigger proportion so that it
you know it expanded the world more and
gave like bigger character factions to
interact so it's not necessarily just
like one guy versus three people it's
like five hundred people versus two
thousand people or something and they
kind of set themselves up for like the
third one just being an all-out war and
I thought that would have been neat
because that world is just so neat and
very Batman vs Dracula
I sure have that used to freak me out as
a kid because it was so dark for a
cartoon and there was a lot of scenes
where Dracula was just without a doubt
just drinking actual blood like he was
biting people there they were bleeding
he was busting into a blood bank and
drinking blood packs there was like kind
of some gore it was a really hardcore
for a Batman animated film as of like
2005 or whenever it came out so you know
like
by today's standards when you have like
stuff like rated-r Killing Joke it kind
of seems like like you know for babbys
but back then that was really awesome I
liked how how far I went penguin vampire
minion yeah that was a thing he was
Xavier how'd your date go that's private
but okay hold on
thoughts on the spectacular spider-man
comics series by Chip sidarsky so far Oh
chip chip chip chip what a chip at eBay
I think chip sidarsky is a funny guy I
like I like his art I think he's a great
artist I really like his our Lord series
that he was writing even though it was
really toned down and kind of
small-scale as a story because it was
like what if star-lord was stuck on
earth for a little while just doing like
normal people stuff and sucking at it
and then decides to try to be a
superhero on earth and it was alright I
liked it I mend that one I think he
sucks at writing spider-man because his
version of spider-man is just some like
socially inept goofball who runs around
just screwing up everything and while I
make jokes about that like in videos I
don't think that should be like the
official interpretation in the [ __ ]
comics there's a whole issue where
spider-man goes on a date and then the
barista tells him that the coffee is
gonna be more expensive than I would be
and he's like upset about that but you
know he sits down with his date and they
start talking about her job cuz she's a
she's a stand-up comedian right and you
know earlier that day he was supposed to
be hanging out with Johnny Storm the
Human Torch but kind of blew him off
because he prioritized the date so Human
Torch shows up there and starts making
the room a little bit hotter so that
spider-man's really sweaty and nervous
on his date right
does it sound at all like an action
story to you or like yeah that sounds
action-packed
it's basically an episode of Seinfeld
but everyone's wearing superhero
costumes it's really abysmal that of all
the things you could do with spider-man
you're like just have him go on a date
like there's a fight scene with kingpin
in like the next issue after that I
think but it's just so boring and they
spend like 90% of it just talking and I
I'm not a fan I really I was excited at
first because of the way chip sidarsky
pitched the book sounded exactly like a
spider-man book out of the 70s or 80s
which I was super excited for upon
seeing his execution he did not give
anything he promised and I'm very upset
Xavier you gonna do a let's play of Lego
Marvel superheroes - I don't know I
might do a review of it so here's enough
so I've done an editorial for you that I
want to pitch that I'm gonna talk about
I want to write I have a rant okay let
me well it's not really a rant it's more
of a thing okay okay so here's the thing
why didn't Ben Grimm on-screen
why does Netflix release all of their
episodes of a show at once because
what's the benefit of that I think it's
a terrible idea I think that has people
like dropping I think that people they
do like it that I think it's ultimately
not a very rewarding experience
mm-my in my opinion they should do what
Star Trek Discovery has been doing and
what Amazon did with the Grand Tour
where they should release at least one
episode a week I think that's a bit more
of a fun experience because if you think
about it
binge watching kind of takes the fun out
of talking up but talking about a show
with your friends because if you're
binging it and your friends are all
binging it you can't just say like oh
hey well hey do you see the latest
episode and you can tell you can't talk
about it
because you're all at different point
within the nine-hour series yeah so if
I'm only like let's say for stranger
things season two I'm only five episodes
in I'm four episodes in I can't talk
about episode five because I haven't
seen it yet if you're talking about it
you're constantly thinking about do I
spoil this do I not spoil this so it's
not really fun for us to talk about it
because we're at different points in the
show so if you have one episode a week
it's easier for everybody to get caught
up on it and we can all have fun
conversations during the week Oh what do
you think about this experience I was
kind of the fun of breaking bad as it
was coming out yeah holy [ __ ] dude did
you just see that new episode where Walt
did X crazy thing and then they could be
like yeah dude I can't wait to see what
happens next episode like do you think
this guy's gonna die do you think this
guy's gonna try this I don't know I
think maybe this character his
motivation would imply that he'd
probably do that you know it was fun
trying to predict what happens next
with binge watching it's just kind of
you sit there for nine hours and then
kind of give like a post-mortem talk
about it with your body like yeah what
do you think of the whole season okay it
kind of started a drag around episode
six yeah and the other part from the
business interesting the one with
Punisher I mean I mean if you think
about it from the business side as well
like you get more publicity from your
show if you don't have it all at once
because if it's all at once then you
have a big publicity weekend and then it
all disappears I mean who talks about
the defenders anymore it was like oh
look here's the defenders okay it's gone
unless you have something like stranger
things where everybody watches it
there's not that much conversation
anymore after it which doesn't make it
as much of a community which it makes it
not as fun you know when you when you
ask the question I wasn't really a
hundred percent on board but now that
you've explained it I think I'm kind of
coming around to your idea like I think
there's a place in the world for binge
watching but I do understand that I'd
like binge watching when when it's not
something new when it's like oh I'm
gonna pick up Stargate for the first
time in watch eight seasons and then
realize I was wasting my life something
like
that's that's what you do with binge
watching someone asked if I think Moon
Knight would be a Marvel net would be a
good Marvel Netflix show yes but I'm
worried they would screw it up they make
it too gritty and down to earth and not
weird enough it needs to be like kind of
like like abstract and psychedelic and
bizarre like I don't like you with it if
it was by like the showrunner of Legion
so I'd be more of an FX thing with yeah
that would be what's his name
there's a guy he was behind him Fargo
and Legion he's got a name I have no
idea who nor Holly I think someone says
I should read venom verse I actually did
read it and I also did a giant rant
about it on Twitter about um all kinds
of stuff that I thought was wrong with
it but also cool that it kind of think
of it as like a mini review so if you go
look on my Twitter and just go search of
venom verse you could probably find the
thread yeah it's not Olly he's the he's
the creator and he wrote it and he's
also a big director on it how do I feel
about Runaways upcoming on Hulu nope I
want to seen the ads but I haven't
investigated it at all another Marvel
Cinematic Universe property it's based
on a comic called runaways and I haven't
not read the runaways comic which is on
my list I've been meaning to get around
to it it does not look interesting via
hi this is gonna sound really weird and
hypocritical but I just can't stand
shows about teenagers because I think
teenager culture is really obnoxious and
stupid I hate people my age I hate drama
hate love triangles I hate you know man
no one understands me school is so rough
that stuff's boring to me like only one
one maybe two stories have ever really
kind of interested me with that
component in them
one of them I'm pretty sure you can all
guess what it is like a teenage
superhero is it spider win yes spider
Glenn obviously totally a big spider
Glenn fan but um yeah I'm not too
interested in runaways I I don't really
feel like checking it out what do you
think of mutants we talked about new
mutants a couple other podcasts ago so
go and check that one out
basically we're opened impassionate
looking show ever and I feel like
everyone working on it didn't want it no
no it's not in humans it's new mutants
Oh new mutants sorry Inhumans I said I
said I said new mutants because the
person who typed it in chat said new
mutants and nonmutants okay I misheard
you uh new mutants I I don't know I mean
it's kind of cool that it they're taking
a different stance on it they're like
instead of just another generic
superhero thing that you've seen a
billion times we'll at least try to have
it be like a horror movie which a
animator like accurate to some of the
comic runs but I haven't read those
animators who are watching this somebody
needs to animate the podcast where we
read sonic fanfiction that would be
amazing animation hmm I have one of the
thought about stranger things that I'd
like to share if you don't mind okay
someone is messaging me on Twitter and
blowing me up about asking to join the
stream
no thank you somebody is yes so here's
my thought about stranger things as
stranger things is teaching us all about
how to do nostalgia what do you think
like how to do eighties retro stuff we
kind of because it's it's it's taking
the tone and the sort of it's taking the
tone of that stories while they're not
being obnoxious about how hey you're
you're on the eighties remember you're
in the eighties and it's not being
obnoxious about it so I like it it well
I like season two so far as much as I've
watched
has had a lot more like licensed 80s
music like hey check it out we're in the
80s remember this song that was popular
then it was in the top 10 list of like
1982 or some [ __ ] yeah but that's like a
minor thing I mean compared to something
like compared to ready player one it's a
lot better oh wow take off those glasses
hey take off those glasses it's like a
reverse of that they live fight scene
now put them back on put them back on
your glasses sir no do it take them off
put extra glasses on now you have
extreme vision you can see into the
future why are we wearing sunglasses
because I um I stole these from my
roommate and then I just thought why not
have a go with the theme the sunglasses
gang I stole these from my grandma and
those are the ones that he also wore in
my x-men 3 retrospective when he played
Cyclops yeah yeah
if anyone hasn't checked that video out
there's a really cool scene in there for
his his review of x-men 3 where he tries
to demonstrate a better way to edit and
shoot a certain scene just to make a
point the whole overall movie doesn't
really have that much art in the editing
or the cinematography yeah so he takes
the scene where Cyclops is standing at
the edge of the lake freaking out
because Jean Grey is like messing with
his head and then he reenacted it with
me in place of Cyclops like I did my
hair up the same way as Cyclops in that
scene I put on glasses and a leather
jacket and like boots and jeans and I
stood there on the edge of an actual
lake that we lived nearby and then we
just kind of like re-enacted the scene
but he filmed it from like way different
angles and edited it in a way more
interesting way and
was just like another fun thing that we
got to film together before he he died
yeah I'm totally dead right now I'm just
speaking to you from beyond the grave
okay
and the grave is known as the Midwest
even in death he's still hypercritical
the midwest is is dead could could they
get a link to that linked to that to the
x-men thing well I can't really go get a
link to it without like derailing the
FaceCam to go like search for it but I
guess I could do is would that be okay
with you well I mean I can just I mean I
don't think we really just search x-men
retrospective part three and go to my
channel or go to my channel um
consciously realistic and it's right in
there okay here we go let's check it out
everyone let's watch it live I just just
just do it what and you'll see the clip
from the video where is it part three
here we go it's like a twenty-one minute
video so which part is it at I'm gonna
I'm gonna go skip through it and I'll
tell you the timecode okay I think it
was like right here-ish like um no 16 16
20 okay here we go
that would direct it
[Music]
that's 1630 but whatever no no your what
a fascist very there you go 16 not 15
stop talking
no original version see yes I do see sir
that was fun I mean it was kind of
obnoxious because there was like right
off-screen and you were very careful to
hide this we were right next to a dock
that like a bunch of kids on a boat were
get like their they were getting off the
boat and stop the video now I did and
put it on high yeah there's a delay
David I'm inch I'm doing fine being the
stream emcee but you're not you're the
stream stream see yeah the stream so
everybody go and watch the video because
it's amazing watch this first so gingers
have no souls can confirm yeah you know
it's a really original clever joke I
have never heard that before
well I I know you personally so don't
worry if I'm a member of the the Weasley
family yeah that's that's what respect
imperative or I'm working on it
I'm just doing other stuff first but
anyway speaking of retrospectives I'm
working on a Hulk retrospective for the
game therefore the movies games and I'd
like to hear your opinion on the Lou
Ferrigno Hulk from the 70s like like
actually like do you actually want to
want to I want to watch her of you of
you doing that talking about Lou
Ferrigno through the lens of like
how comic-book accurate is it yes do it
do it
I would watch maybe someday I mean that
here's the thing I have like no shortage
of things to review there's so many
video games so many movies so many
cartoons I I can bus I'd if I ever
started to actually kind of run out I
could just start reviewing actual comics
on their own I have you could become
like Cara limitless supply it could
become winged Cara one day you know I've
actually been kind of afraid of
comparisons to him so that's one of the
reasons I've avoided directly just
reviewing comics on their own but I mean
you know III guess I've tried to also
avoid his videos so I don't accidentally
like parrot something he says gingers
are always depressed can confirm Spider
Man says by the way it's my birthday I'm
14 now happy birthday why do you hate
ultimate spider-man Xavier what do you
mean the comic or the show because all
the comic is alright the designs for
contest of slashers are dope yeah thanks
to Brandon for those he's that you did a
great job on them hey remember when
ghost in the shell' was actually a thing
that was gonna happen
remember when that doesn't happen
remember when that just completely
bombed yeah that was amazing this year
that was this year it came out in March
it feels like an eternity ago I feel
like that was like a 2015 thing that was
a 2017 thing ghost in the shell' the
movie remember when nobody cared about
it yeah you mean five minutes ago yeah
okay I was just thinking about that
because I ran across the trailer and I
just thought about how much of an epic
fail it was because it was kind of funny
because there were three movies epic
fail on ironically
who doesn't say epic fail and ironically
it didn't make his budget here's the
thing I was going to talk about this but
here's a good example about it movie
studios do not get 100% of the
box-office gross
they won't usually get close to 40% so
that it did not break even plus there's
budget and then there's marketing budget
which they don't reveal so it it did not
make its money back I'd estimate they
lost millions of dollars on that Josh is
an idiot he couldn't figure out the
stream overlay when we were screaming
spider-man I figured it out in like five
minutes when we were setting this up so
I wrote a video about this a while ago
talking about how nobody really
understands box office numbers like
there was an episode of red letter media
called breaking down box office numbers
which was just hugely factually
incorrect so what's up [ __ ]
Esther stream crashed by David's
roommate shout-out to that guy he's done
this like six times on the podcast but
usually they're not live so we don't
have to worry about it cuz David can
just edit it out there's one podcast
that I was supposed to edit and release
but I didn't guess I got a little lazy
but you know so but anyway uh should I
should find something to talk about are
you gonna do a let's play of Spider Man
ps4 no I'll do a review on it but not a
let's play or if I do do it let's play
it'll be after I get done reviewing it
because if you're playing through a
video game for the first time and you're
doing the let's play you're gonna be
like half focused on it and wanting to
like spend most of your time talking
like like I know this from what I played
outlast two eventually I went through
and played through it all the way by
myself and still hated it but when
you're trying to do a let's play you
always end up focusing a little bit too
much on
talking so I feel like it would kind of
like lessen my experience with the game
or make it harder for me to enjoy
because then I'd be just just rambling
at it and it wouldn't really be like
engaging me so it would it would hurt
the review if I played through it as a
let's play then did a review based on
that so I'd want to do that second all
genders are trial gingers are
transgender and homosexual can confirm
someone said someone asked me if I'm
gonna make a better Batman costume
earlier I don't I don't know who-who
said that I think it was Dark Knight fan
no I think my Batman costume was
hilarious because I threw it together in
like a single afternoon and get was
supposed to the point of that was
supposed to be it's really crappy I'm
actually really happy with how your
Riddler costume came out for that it
looked pretty good for something thrown
together in a relatively quick amount of
time
like we just in a single day we were
just like hey let's go on a random
shopping spree getting like costume
parts for this dumb thing so we bought
you like a woman's jacket that was black
and then spray painted it green and
purple I think and then put like a giant
question mark on the back and then we
couldn't find a hat for you for the life
of us so we found a black one and then
painted that and then immediately like 5
minutes later after we got done with it
we went to a different store just to go
get groceries and then we found a green
bowler hat and I was like god dammit I
think I still got some pictures from the
day when he made the spider-man costume
and from the day he did this and here's
one of them oh yeah I love that picture
I think it's a savior giving the middle
finger to the audience as Batman it's
amazing I guess the dryer is done hold
on is Dain in the in the stream
oh hey he's talking to Joey Joey and
Dane are some too
- cool fellas I appreciate those guys
they're really cool what are your
thoughts on the Spider Man on a
potential spider-man 2099 Netflix series
oh they they would never be able to do
that that budget would be way too high
or if they did your when when there's
the title that Netflix wanted to borrow
an extra 1.6 billion dollars to spend on
content they would leave on a huge
budget for a Content on Netflix and
here's my problem with that spying 1.6
million dollars of hot dogs isn't gonna
make me want to buy hot dogs if I want
Turkey I feel like we always end up
going back to some kind of food based
allegory that involves Turkey well I
love turkey sandwiches that is your best
video that you've ever made or ever will
make Wow
thanks for the vote of confidence you
can trust me
I'm always good for that that video that
you showed up late for and didn't help
on I had a dental appointment okay yeah
everyone had a dental appointment you
know how hard it was to film that
because I had like 20 extras lined up
and then maybe like 16 of them cancelled
like five minutes before we were about
to shoot like they just were like now
I'm not feeling it
like Jackson that bastard I was like hey
you want to you want to come help in
film and he's like yeah I'll be there
then uh he texted me like later he's
like yeah I slept in till 4:00 p.m. so
sorry
who needs Jackson anyone man he's only
Jackson he can go get his astronaut
degree and go to space and die for all I
care he can get killed by an alien yeah
everybody's killed by aliens in space I
mean everybody who has gone to space has
been killed by aliens are you telling
you that you don't know this how did I
make your screen like widescreen because
a second ago it was like kind of
letterbox
I don't know but then I clicked on it a
little bit too much in it hey look
here's my mouse it's on your nose cool I
don't care
stop hiding your true emotions don't bow
great hair it's amazing but it went
widescreen just as I went just as I put
my face right in front of the camera
still doing the mouse thing anyway let's
go look at more viewer questions no all
right let's read some more fanfic did
you finish Batman abyss fan series oh
yes I watched like the first two
episodes of that I thought it was really
cool kind of reminded me of like judged
no it is not Tom Holland in the
reflection of my glasses its turkey
sandwiches for all michael kota asks
how's it going it's going alright live
stream so i have a question for you
what's what what's the most embarrassing
movie that you've cried at that's made
you feel something that you're kind of
embarrassed that you made felt something
about or did you did that ever happen to
you is that just me I'm trying to think
like what was the last time I got really
emotional at a movie well there's Logan
I got really emotional in that one I
kind of predicted how that was gonna go
I mean he kind of knew that I mean you
already knew that it was gonna happen
but it was also very sad when it did
happen yeah another one that happened
for me was the Spock documentary for the
love of Spock that's kind of
embarrassing to admit that I get sad at
that but the ending you're like oh the
feels yeah I mean it's Leonard Nimoy so
you wouldn't I mean who wouldn't guess
that she cried all day because she's
like like she loves Spock specifically
like old starch
like when she was a kid that was her
first crush on TV and he was so beside
herself because she has a signature from
all of the currently living Star Trek
peoples she was gonna wait till Spock
would eventually show up at Comic Con
and get cuz she has this t-shirt that
she has a signature from all of them on
and she was gonna wait till he showed up
at Comic Con and have him sign it so she
could have the full set because it's a
spot t-shirt and then he passed away and
she's like dammit but she has a shirt
that has the signature of all of the
ones that are currently alive well
that's too bad
morbid fact that thing's probably gonna
get a lot more valuable as they stop
being life ya [ __ ] up is that like
your stuff you own is way more valuable
after you die so you can't even like use
it mm-hmm
nice shot of the back of your head
mm-hmm you know the other like the other
the other Star Trek Depp that made me
feel sad was when was what's-his-name
Anton Yelchin died oh yeah that sucked a
lot of Star Trek related tragedies
mm-hmm you know for a while before they
said they were gonna cast like a super
young actor for it I was like hey you
know Anton Yelchin would make a pretty
good spider-man oh well I mean while
they were casting in they're like ooh
that's good Doolittle Brian or Logan
Lerman or the guy who plays Peeta yeah I
was like Peter no Peter from from Peter
Holmes Oh yep from hungry gams
yeah I still maintain that hungry games
is pretty good the books are amazing the
movies are tough bloggers they're still
very good and I still I still maintain
that hungry gams is better than anybody
gets a credit for the other yne stuff
isn't that good but hungry games is good
no yes I will fight you I'll fight I'll
fight you so I will fight you why don't
you come over here and say that to my
face
I will Thanksgiving break you're coming
back Thanksgiving break yep
I told you this already we can hang out
and watch movies yep we can continue to
not binge watch Babylon 5 together oh
boy I can't wait to not watch Babylon 5
I'm so excited I haven't seen you it's
so long I can finally put no tears for
that thing you said and no it's not
Twilight but better acted Twilight is
here's the thing is that Twilight is why
like Rome amazingly actor Twilight is
about the romance but Hunger Games has a
romance in it isn't primarily about the
romance what I got would you rather Nene
a podcast no would you rather read fan
fiction or Ernest Cline oh oh boy that's
hard transition for spoiling stranger
things season 2 yeah
banish him from this discord server for
that babe I could do it I'm a mod tech
the fabled wolf among us I actually have
a bunch of fables comic books I haven't
read yet but wolf among us is my
favorite telltale game that they've done
so far and I'm very happy that they're
doing a season 2 finally because I feel
like that's way overdue David what is
your favorite Star Trek series in the
next generation easily I love the next
generation but there's some really good
episodes of Star Trek Voyager and Star
Trek The Next Deep Space nine like I'm
Xavier can tell you he watched in the
pale moonlight which is the Deep Space
nine Episode which is pretty rad right
yeah we'll talk about that Deep Space
nine is the one with the captain the the
the Blackman okay you said it before I
did alright
cool yeah I like that episode because it
was wasn't that the one where they they
framed someone for murder to like avoid
it like create an international incident
but that'll like kind of well the
purpose was to get the Romulans into the
war because of the Klingons and the
Federation couldn't win against the
Dominion on their own and then they go
up some really shady stuff to get that
happening what I'm not whispering very
rude things my job stares barking and I
wanted I just I wish I could close the
door but I can't why because the cats
need to get down here cuz it's where
their food is they don't need to eat
they kind of do though no animals don't
need to eat thoughts on Doctor Who he
doesn't like it I like I have one right
here his own smoochy
he's four months old we adopted him from
a parking lot no not literally but he's
my friend he is a cool good Katniss he's
probably like in a couple of episodes of
couch potatoes but as like a small
kitten that's like he is but I haven't
edited them yet you were taking way too
long a DAT those look my file my mind my
files got destroyed so there's another
one I'm editing it right now I just have
school you're a school Xavier would you
want a spider-man I'm gonna game now
yeah I'm going to a real movie I'm going
to real well you're the ultimate
spider-man Cho Xavier well the sense of
humor is obnoxious and not very fitting
for spider-man
I kind of hate that they put him in
charge of a team of like young Avengers
but made them kind of useless and not
really important I think also that the
voice actor I don't like very much Drake
Bell I mean he's he's great and Drake
and Josh but a spider-man doesn't fit at
all the action scenes just kind of bore
me so you're just joshing and Drake and
Josh
can David please strap you to a chair
and force you to watch Doctor Who who
says I haven't done that already
he kind of did actually it didn't work
but I did it I just kind of got bored
and stopped paying attention and I just
started staring at the floor some about
some kind of space Titanic and I was
like like two minutes into the episode
like they ripped this off from Futurama
but they did it better than she trauma
bit I said doctor who actually made you
feel things made me feel bored well it
made me feel things that were actually
like feelings questions now Xavier are
you spider Jake's dad internet universe
probably would I rather have a
spider-man 2099 or spider-man noir show
or movie movie 2099 is better what's so
basically shows sobriety besides the
original vs. Mechagodzilla - oh you mean
God Godzilla against Mechagodzilla yes
those titles get really weird Twilight
is trash very perceptive of you
it's a very hot take but thanks for
getting your hot take from 2011 I mean I
missed I missed these missed the
Twilight jokes from 2011 that actually
like remember when Twilight was actually
a thing that people cared about Dave did
you watch because some are better than
the others the one where uh the one
David Tennant the the creepy guy from
the Jessica Jones have you tied the
David on the chair and make him much
that god-awful Batman Robin movie who
says I haven't already watched the
Batman and Robin movie that's fine who
says I don't love it
it's his favorite I love it the Iceman
Cometh who killed the dinosaurs
I've aged love that it's you're not
going to put me in the cooler I love it
so much David how do you feel about the
new doctor if at this point doctor who
hasn't been good since pretty much since
David Tennant left so I don't really
care anymore I don't think it's gonna be
any better or any worse I'm curious to
see what the new showrunner does but I'm
not very optimistic I'm just giving up
on Doctor Who at this point it's been
it's been sucking for years if any
superhero hasn't gotten a game yet could
get a game who would it be and why well
I want to say Moon Knight because he's
one of my favorites but I feel like that
would just be like basically a like a
like a copy and paste of a Batman Arkham
game because they're so similar in terms
of like combat and stealth and [ __ ]
George Clooney is the best Batman the
flash could have a pretty cool video
game the flash has are you excited for
the new that's set for March 2019 or
know it's it's it's tense day 2019
gambits back on behave me I did no sir
I'm not excited because I don't like
Channing Tatum and I don't think gambit
is particularly interesting I've read a
couple of books with him it's never
really never caught me as a character
but that's why he's more preference I'm
not saying he it's objectively going to
be bad or the gambit is bad well Doug
Liman was interested for a while I was
interested cos Doug Liman
but then Doug Liman left for dark
universe and then he left for chaos
walking which is currently your favorite
Deadpool story probably like the first
30 issues of the movie no no no it's the
game he loves the game most of all
right no well anyway probably the the
first 30 issues of the series by Joe
Kelly is really good there like that one
I also like Deadpool Merc with a mouth
was like this short miniseries that was
like I think like 15 issues or something
that was really good good is your
favorite spider-man movie I don't know
none of them yeah I don't think there's
ever been a perfect method of enjoying
spider-man at this point it is in my
heart I believe wholeheartedly that the
cartoons the video games and the movies
will always pale in comparison for me
this is not for everyone but for me to
the comics I think reading spider-man
not not currently current spider-man
comics or garbage Dan Slott and chip
sidarsky have no J mass media spider-man
generally really saw it jammed demat
police a lot of other writers like that
other one who did the spectacular series
from like 2002 or something I think
spider-man comics are probably more
interesting to me than any other medium
so I don't know I I really just don't
have an opinion on the movies anymore
they're a thing that exists the movies
are you going I think he's mid Alliance
to know why would I ever do that I think
we've talked to I think we've talked to
death about a spider-man homecoming I I
think that a lot of people kind of a lot
of people just sort of forced themselves
to like spider-man homecoming I think
it's it's got some flaws a lot of flaws
and also I'm kind of tired it because
I'm just tired of MCU movies in general
so I think that it well it's it's also
the third it's the third spider-man
reboot and it's the
let's see 1 2 3 ASM 1 a.m. 2 it's the
6th movie it's the 6th spider-man movie
and it's like the 14th MCU movie or
something so it's kind of weird kind of
all getting sick of it at this point
yeah I mean we've explained pretty
extensively in other podcasts why MCU
movies are not bad not good until kind
of grading because it it's starting to
feel very se me it's nothing to feel
like you're seeing the same movie on a
loop just because they are very like
they just the tone the writing style the
action scenes the colors the
cinematography everything is always
pretty much the same and I understand
that you need to regulate it so that
there's not like brand confusion like
everyone can go see a movie
yeah like DC those movies are all over
the place in terms of tone like Wonder
Woman is one thing but Batman V Superman
is a totally different and then Suicide
Squad is just garbage that's debatable
I'm not a big fan of that one because it
fails a lot of basic filmmaking rules
yeah but it's just poorly put together
it's got awful performances it's got
unlikable characters and the plot is
terrible also there's no action scenes
hold on
well I ever livestream injustice to
Xavier all-caps um
no or maybe I mean I already did once
with Josh but uh if you go check out my
other live streams I do now that I
finally figured out how to use OBS I do
want to do a playthrough of Batman
Arkham Asylum and just give my thoughts
on it while I'm playing kind of like an
elongated review / let's play but while
I'm also interacting with chat and I'm
thinking about starting that tomorrow
but and Rex 'men or Andrey x-man however
you pronounce it if you're still on the
stream I wanted to ask you if you could
help me write on the and Rec see if you
can help me come up with another stream
overlay you could say Andre Andre yeah
what's your opinion of beware in the
Batman I only watch like one episode and
it seemed alright but I
was just kind of like put off by the
animation style because I thought
Batman's had look really weird Lars a
stupid complaint but still just just
barbar of the Batman what do you think
of the new Spidey cartoon on Disney gee
I don't get asked this every five
minutes I don't watch it so I don't know
if you're asking me I don't know I've
watched like one episode didn't like it
doesn't mean it was alright it wasn't
terrible I just don't feel like watching
any more of it you see here's the thing
people sometimes misunderstand what it
means to be a fan of something they may
think like just because it has
spider-man in the title you need to all
watch every single episode of it so you
can complain about it if the show looks
like garbage and you don't want to watch
it you can just not watch it like in the
granted you don't get to complain about
it because you haven't seen it but it
just doesn't look interesting to me and
I'm not gonna waste time watching a show
I'm like 90% sure I'm not gonna enjoy
just because it has spider-man in it you
know like that's it's a waste of time
it's like it's like reading all the Dan
Slott Marvel comics from that let me
have a rant here about this okay so this
is this is how not to be a fan so I'm as
soon as some people might not might be
aware of I actually have family yes I'm
not a robot so my brother is a huge star
or Star Wars fan and this is how not to
be a fan by the way
so here is the so here's what he said to
me so so he went and saw rogue one let's
see probably three times once in
theaters on opening weekend then in like
IMAX 3d and then again and then he said
I'll see it once if it's good and twice
if it's bad no no no no I'll see it once
if it's bad twice if it's good sorry
mixed up I mean I thought I mean I
thought he was seeing typhus stuff it's
bad because he saw rogue one and he
thought that was good
understandable but you get my point
that's not what you should do you should
just because you're a fan doesn't
you have to like everything or buy every
toy or see every movie you you you still
need to be an intelligent person who
thinks about things it just means that
you like something that's all it really
means yeah so don't do what my brother
does and see them to see a movie just
because it's got the name on it if you
ask me that's the logo on the front like
oh it's a Star Wars movie I'm obligated
to see it if you ask me that's why
Star Wars is so crappy these days is
because they don't have to try they just
know they're gonna get you to see it if
you have a Star Wars movie it's gonna
make a billion dollars or more no matter
what you do you can do yeah really
anything and if it has Star Wars on the
front and if the trailer is edited to
look really nostalgic like stuff
everyone recognizes it doesn't matter
what the actual movies about billion
dollars like you know what's gonna
happen you don't have to put any thought
into it I don't think the new Star Wars
movies are complete garbage or anything
I just I don't think they're garbage
they're just completely and utterly
creatively bankrupt all they're doing is
like episode 7 was just a remake of
episode 4 and episode 8 is gonna be a
remake of episode 5 I think there was
already a scene with like the walkers in
the snow and then the ships flying at
them I can already see them reenacting
the opening on off and then it's going
to end instead of and of course of
course it's gonna be Yoda and instead of
Yoda and Luke it's Luke and yeah marry
ray I'm sorry Mary Sue but you tried
Xavier madness yeah he talked about that
earlier
oh hey levantus
a lot is some people are telling me to
turn up my mix sense oh one sec how do I
do that is it this do I do this yes just
shout louder okay like should I just be
louder is that fine
yes everyone type in the chat Alex has
good microphone quality if it's working
I have the mice mirror elevators that
make me you have panic attacks you see
where it's just generally getting
smaller
um yes Xavier uh that doesn't really
help Alex has good microphone quality
alright if I'm just louder it works I
needed to stop talking quiet
[Music]
are you done no are you you know I
haven't eaten in like 23 hours I should
probably eat food soon well since when
is this unusual for you I don't know I
should start taking care of myself
better I really I keep forgetting to you
you should my sleep schedule is garbage
I'm sick all the time I think all this
requires the sleeping I did today cuz
I've been I basically woke up like
thirty minutes before we started trying
to stream more or less right pretty much
yeah yeah so there's a kid so there's a
kid on my hall who like like lasts like
a week ago or something like that
he got up for his 8 o'clock class and
then he had to take a nap and then he
slept through his the rest of his
classes that day so did you did you did
you hear that or not
[Laughter]
anyway um oh now you have a hoodie look
out everyone he's a cool guy in the 90s
yo my name's Ben Riley y'all anyway uh
let's see what uh what else
alex has goods Mick quality with a No
all right cool that's helpful good you
thanks everyone hi Damien my buddy LaVey
inist is in here he's a cool dude Xavier
what is your favorite run on the
daredevil comics I haven't read enough
of them
I I know this is gonna be a
controversial statement but I did like
the ones that Kevin Smith wrote kind of
in like the beginning of volume 2 with
the the death of Karen page it's not
really a spoiler because it happened in
like 2001 and if you don't know that
happened then it's okay to spoil things
if they're 16 years old okay
Snape kills Dumbledore yeah yeah um did
you know that the same year look
everyone David is a g-man I can't wait
for everyone in the chat to say that
you're gonna shoot up a school don't
make jokes like that a thug cuz you know
we're we would rip monetization Xavier
what do you plan on reviewing spongebob
battle for bikini bottom or the
spongebob movie game where what huh
bullseye has a habit of killing
Daredevils girlfriends yeah yeah why
didn't you just kill daredevil who the f
is Karen page you watch daredevil was on
a daredevil season one and two one's
good twos kinda okay it felt it falls
off of the second hand is probably the
most solid single season of a TV show
I've ever seen it suffered just
Jones yeah Jessica Jones I really liked
this not everyone agree end to end and I
think season 3 of Babylon 5 is pretty
amazing but you haven't seen it because
you're not cool enough to watch good TV
I mean I wish I was this cool yeah I've
got my hoodie yeah put it on put on that
one as well put on the glasses and then
we just start fighting in an alley I
love that movie put on the hood yes I
have a neckbeard because I'm dressing up
for as Riker and Riker I was in
neckbeard I'm planning to shave
Halloween costume abroad I'm party
planning to shave it right after
Halloween though because I don't like
neck beards normally so for the sake of
a costume yeah I'm doing it for the sake
of a costume other people are asking
questions don't answer them
you heard there's a horror movie based
on the x-men franchise it's called x-men
origins Wolverine that's not a horror
movie that's that's pretty good
removing mr. comedy you know I I saw
something funny once where someone said
that it seems more like the x-men
origins movie is a tie-in for the game
than the other way around
because the game is so much better no no
x-men origins is not a comedy do you
remember that stare scene where it with
the ladders resetting yes he's like it
looks like like a scene from Roger
Rabbit because his laws are so yeah he's
superimposing he's just and the the fire
escape is falling down and just getting
like it makes no sense how he's cutting
it like that but just it looks so yummy
and it's it's
were so amazing the how can you say that
that's not a comedy oh I
my buddy Damien asked what do I think of
deceased hero never heard of it I'm
wearing a deceased I told you about it
before we start recording the number
zero is my personal favorite superhero
I'm wearing my deceased hero hoodie
right now David is the Unabomber yeah I
buy it that was before I was born
probably unless it happened after I was
born in Kasich it didn't happen it's
weird being like like delayed on the
stream because sometimes I look at it
and I look look over here and I'm
looking back at myself and then and it
cuts to different things
hold on this apparently my phone is like
super behind on whatever is happening
okay more questions I'm not going to
tell you what's happening question
what's the question
the question I know yeah DC character
called the question look him up right
now yes right now the question here we
go
he's I he's this guy Wow yeah I have a
t-shirt underneath my jacket he has no
face he runs around and he solves crimes
with his lack of face so I don't have a
face he believes in conspiracy theories
about how the government is working for
aliens or some BS and war Shaq is
actually technically based on him
because Alan Moore wanted to write a
book with DC characters but they're like
nah you can't do this super dark weird
story with violence and apocalypse and
and other dark themes so he's like
alright I'll just make a character
that's like similar enough and that's
it's the rorshach fun fact fun fact
yeah what's the fun fact what's the fun
thing tell me the fun thing tell me I've
got all the facts
stop stop copy stop stop that stop act
what's the fun parent how long have we
been going about an hour 20 oh wow well
we should probably wrap it up soon
Xavier I had to leave because of an
emergency did you answer my call
questions I'm sorry I did not I didn't
start looking up the stream chat until a
little bit late are you excited for
daredevil season 3 and are you gonna
play Marvel vs. Capcom infinite infinite
infinite implement I've covered infinity
Wars you know I wanted to check it out
it's I mean I played it a little bit at
this gaming convention thing that Josh
and Kyle took me to it was fun I mean I
know a lot of people hate it
but it seemed alright what was the other
half of that question daredevil season 3
I don't know if they focus it more like
season 1 and stop trying to split it up
between you know two completely
unrelated
it'll be better I'm kind of tired of the
whole of the whole Netflix Marvel thing
it feels really formulaic like did you
see the tweet that i retweeted on
twitter where it said hot take all
Marvel Netflix shows start out the
Marvel Netflix shows start out good but
then turn into a hot mess by the end I
did I disagree I think daredevil season
1 and Jessica Jones season 1 are very
solid
I think but but here's the thing are
those anomalies though or the regular
because it seems like everything else
hasn't been good and there are more bad
there's more bad stuff than good stuff
none of them have been ok well I think
not to say cage Luke Cage and iron fists
are pretty bad I had a hard time
finishing both of those defenders just
kind of fizzled out and got like really
underwhelming towards the end mm-hmm
like it started yeah that wasn't all
agree with it started out really strong
daredevil season 1 started out really
great and was like we're gonna have this
whole crazy long arc with the Punisher
and it was amazing because like the
actor playing Punisher is fantastic and
it's really well written it's really
awesome and then Elektra showed up and
it got more on Elektra showed up and
then there everyone
whenever Frank Castle was not on screen
everyone should be asking where is Frank
Castle because he started like stealing
everyone's scenes because he was so much
more interesting than the other
characters so it was like whatever
Elektra shows up you're like ok alright
let's go get through this alright ok I
get it
his secret organization of ninjas wanna
take over the world blah blah blah
something about being some kind of
prophecy get back to Punisher I want to
see what he's doing
oh he's in prison now and he's fighting
dudes in the hallway this is awesome and
cuts back to Elektra and you're like ok
she has a history was stick the same as
like daredevil did the you know the
rough childhood she's an assassin all
right come on Punisher Punisher oh he
escaped through the prison that's
amazing I can't wait to see what he does
next like it's so weird and one-sided
you only want to watch The Punisher
stuff because Elektra isn't bad just not
nearly as cool so I'm gonna say that I'm
not really all that interested in Marvel
Netflix anymore because it's just too
much of an obligation to watch all of
these different shows that I'm just not
all that interested in yeah so like
when's the next episode of bad comic art
oh yeah next year we probably gonna try
and do it monthly and then school
started and then I just like yeah well I
was willing to do it whenever you were
but you'd never maybe as a joke in the
next episode we should announce that
it'll be a daily series and then wait
like another six months to do one yeah
yep are you excited for Paris games week
spider-man ps4 tomorrow no no do you
want in spider-man ps4 I don't it's a 38
so Paris games week react live on stream
tomorrow
if you had to pick one Green Lantern in
the Justice League movie who would you
it would it be Hal Jordan or Jon Stewart
either Jon Stewart or Kyle Rayner I
don't like Hal Jordan Xavier will you
live sorry man the movie game with Josh
is a continuation from the first ps1
thing no that's up to Josh I think he's
in the stream watching right now he is
where is he I don't know he just
messaged me a couple of times telling me
to answer Josh if you're watching uh say
something can I die yes you can you can
die says please answer oh wait Xavier
will you like yeah she's these questions
guys can you review the infamous games
maybe I don't know if it's not
necessarily like based on a comic book I
feel like it's not like people aren't
nearly as excited to hear my thoughts on
it like the splatterhouse review for
example just kind of just kind of flew
under the radar for most people just
because they're like well this isn't
anything I recognize um
I'm not bitter about it it's just like
yeah I'll probably try and stick more to
directly comic book
stuff but maybe there's a market for
that I don't know we'll try it if you
could get rid of one comic book
character who would it be and why
the watcher he's already dead oh good
well make it that he never existed you
know I don't ever really blame the comic
characters I don't think any of them are
like like I blame the writers for the
characters being annoying not the
characters themselves I think any
character can be cool but like if you're
a bad writer you just make them
obnoxious like I wouldn't want to erase
Miles Morales from existence
I just want Bendis to stop writing him
but if there's one character from a
comic that I think is super obnoxious
no matter the writer like that's just
their personality is just being the
scrappy-doo of comics space scrappy-doo
of comics is Norrell winters from
spider-man she works at like The Daily
Bugle or Noah some other competitor
newspaper I can't remember now it's been
complicated
Norrell winters is the most annoying
comic book character ever and every time
she talks it bugs me so much that I've
I've just taken to just gliding past the
pages with her in them like I just skim
read them or just not even read the the
word bubbles that she says because even
if it like hurts the story like there's
six pages of her talking I'll just skip
through them you know made the like 2010
or whatever Greg Rucka run of Punisher
way harder to read there's some central
character in that you know here's
something we should do anyway stop
reading the questions for a second I had
and I have an idea we need to do a couch
potatoes of ready player one when it
comes out because I've we've read we've
read we've read poetry from Ernest Cline
we've read elements from his novels
we've read all of it were you reminded
of Ernest Cline because I was talking
about bad writers yes so we need to do
couch potatoes like we did for valerian
about ready player one would you be down
to that yeah yeah probably we're
probably gonna be at school so it's
probably gonna be like a digitally
reproduced and last we're on spring
break might be not we could do it on
spring break maybe that might come when
Schoen side try do I'm saying over to
the theater and spend money on ready
player one though it'd be worth it for
the for for mainly I could just get us
like like a box of old junk from like a
toy store and then just pour it all over
myself and that's basically the same
experience Tron remember Iron Giant hey
look over here it's the video game
characters you recognize oh my god if
they've got the rifle from Halo oh boy
there's master cheese there's Freddie
Krueger
there's the DeLorean it's like loot
crate but two hours long and yelling at
you and directed by Steven Spielberg
he's directing it I thought he was only
producing it he's directing it Oh God
how long has it been since he's directed
something he directed bridge of spies in
2015 and he's directing a movie that's
coming out for the award season this
year called the post which is about you
know the post washington post when they
when they did like some scandal or
something
my favorite man line about ready player
one ready player one is a terrible book
and it will be a terrible movie yes yep
someone asked if I want a live stream
dead space I don't want to watch that
yeah nobody will watch them you can't
see what I'm crying a little because of
the dead space plate
dead space is a good game but it's not
very fun to stream I think it is I I
don't know it just depends on your
audience if they're not into it they're
not into it
you know that's not to force it so yeah
here's the thing a lot of the people
begging me to bring back dead space I
think the number of them equals about
like 30 people that are asking over and
over yep
it's not like this giant audience that
will watch every episode like you know
and get it up to at least a thousand
views plus plus all the other ones got
to monetize cuz YouTube is like oh hey
it's a horrible book but I have some
faith in the movie well here's the thing
since when is Steven Spielberg directed
a good movie since like the night he
directed good movies in the early 2000s
in the late 90s but since then it's been
remember AI artificial intelligence
remember remember those world war ii
movies that your mom made you watch but
you kind of got bored with otherwise
spider Jake says I don't give an F about
dead space I haven't watched any of
Xavier Let's Plays that's exactly your
support that's very kind of you
please answer if you were trapped in a
room with Batgirl or Supergirl what
would you do um I tried to escape with
their help try to escape with their help
probably I mean if you got Supergirl in
the room you wouldn't really be trapped
in the room you just ask her to like
exactly just punch them all and then
you'd be done unless this kryptonite I
mean that's that's kind of a lot of
people are asking for infamous maybe
that maybe I should give that a shot you
know dude Hulk instead Xavier who do you
think is better Hulk or Wolverine I like
Wolverine a little bit more I've
actually started getting into Wolverine
comics recently like I read Wolverine
max
first just because it was short and it
was a little bit uh like harder-edged
because I like me some some darker
stories I like the Marvel max stuff a
lot except for Deadpool max that's
garbage
but Punisher max but bad no no wait debt
Deadpool max mmm-hmm oh this no what's
the max name there what does that mean
okay Max is just like this Marvel
imprint that has no rules applied to it
so they can basically just do whatever
so if they want like nudity or extreme
Gore or cussing like like you can say
whatever word you want and they'll just
publish it so just like absolutely free
of any kind of censorship
that's why Punisher Max is so like
hard-edged and everyone's saying the
f-word and everyone's cutting each other
in half with automatic there's the Irish
people doing the Irish things the
kitchen Irish arc which was awesome
there's yeah so um there's uh there's
the max Marvel imprint
I've been reading a couple of those I
think the thing that bugs me and about
Deadpool Max is that Deadpool is not
even really the main character and they
make it his sidekick Bob from Hydra
instead except they make no CIA agents
and they mostly just run around doing
really really stupid things and there's
not really any kind of plot progression
Deadpool is like a complete nonentity in
his own story because he's really just
there to be wacky and break things and
it's I don't know I feel like the author
wanted to write a completely different
book that didn't have Deadpool in it so
he tried to make him is like useless and
not important as possible so he could do
a book about like a goofy CIA agent
named Bob who's accidentally part of
some kind of government's conspiracy and
gets framed for assassinating a
politician whatever he's just like I'll
put Deadpool in there too I guess
Deadpool's got to put the Deadpool name
in the phone box
I mean it is kind of fun in cathartic to
see Deadpool like finally able to swear
but he only does it like twice and no
like 30 issues that that had so it was
like what why what was even the point if
you have a book where Deadpool is
allowed to say the f-word why would you
have him do it so little and I guess you
could like say well maybe they had just
a lot of constraint know all the other
characters are cussing up a storm I
don't know mm-hmm you know why don't you
know I think let's give a little update
about what's going on on the channels
you're working on the whole crap I
talked about that tell me about that
okay so I'm working on a review I can't
tell if it's gonna be I'm thinking that
it's gonna be like three individual
videos maybe but it's gonna be the Hulk
2003 game on xbox Hulk ultimate
destruction on ps2 and then the 2008
game on xbox 360 and there's like there
was this ps1 game but you're only doing
three of them that you're gonna count as
the official retrospective oh yeah I was
like with the spider-man retrospective I
didn't go back and review the Atari game
I only really talked about the ones from
like the past three you play yeah that
you really care yeah well yeah sure
there's like other people who went back
and did reviews of the the ones that I
didn't really count but really for me
it's just like talking about the 3d
games mm-hmm as long as I can get a copy
of them I have no idea how to get a copy
of that ps1 Hulk game nor do I really
want to because I saw some stuff from it
and it looks a little little not great
but uh I got the review written for The
Hulk 2003 game that's done I just have
to wait till I don't have a cold anymore
so I can record the audio without
sounding all definitely in bad that was
one of the reasons that the Arkham
Knight review took so long to come out
is because I had a super terrible cold
while I was trying to
Kord it so I had to wait till a day
where it kind of subsided a little but
you can still kind of hear it if you
listen closely on the Arkham Knight
review and then it came back in like
full force like a day later and then
over like the the next like two weeks it
just kept getting worse and worse till I
was so then we recorded the Batman thing
out in that parking lot
so my Batman voice sounded really messed
up and in gravelly not because I was
doing the voice but that's just that's
what I sounded like at the time so it
kind of worked I guess but for this one
I'm not really there's not really a bit
I can do that would involve me sounding
like a ghoul from fallout so I'm gonna
try on my channel besides podcast so
what I'm working on is that right now
I'm editing the new couch potatoes so
I'm gonna be working on couch potatoes
Robocop right now so that should come
out as soon as I finish editing whenever
that is and then after that I wrote em
my little editorial on musical stuff so
I can talk about music for one episode
just to see if anybody cares and they
probably won't so after that I'm
probably gonna start work on either a
couch potatoes or because they've got
like seven of them stored up or x-men
retrospective part 4 which is which I
mean that's gonna be bring up an
interesting angle what do you think I
haven't written a script for x-men
retrospective part four if you count it
as x-men origins Wolverine you think
that you like if you're in the stream
tell me do you want me to review x-men
origins Wolverine I won't because right
now right now I have scripts through
Days of Future past and I could I could
just move on and working on x-men first
class because technically Wolverines a
solo movie so you don't really have to
include it as part of that list but I
mean I can really put it on there if you
really want me to talk about it but
here's the thing is that require a lot
more work because and after watch it a
couple of times to take notes and write
a script
and then do the editing and all the
gathering clips and all that a game
review because it doesn't take nine
hours to experience it once you know
there doesn't think I don't stay up
until three morning 3:00 in the morning
recording game footage like you did so
[Music]
that's true I was up until God knows
when yesterday writing a script for
that's a disadvantage that I have over
you yeah yeah my sleep schedules garbage
Hey
origins review would be hilarious
probably not a lot of people now because
we're boring but 90 it still it stayed
fairly steady it's still at 96 which is
what it peaked at okay everyone in the
chat please if you have any kind of
skill with source filmmaker or any other
equivalent animation program please let
me know because I'm sure you've all seen
the Ultimate Alliance sketch that my
friend my good friend scrubs animate did
with with the Iceman thing him and I are
collaborating on a much bigger project
like like like something that's like 20
minutes long at most and we are gonna
need a lot of help so if you're good at
animating or even if you're just good at
like modeling let's say characters and
environments you know in like blender or
something that can be ported into source
filmmaker that would be helpful as well
so if you can model like the interior of
a room or if you can make a character
model based on like some pictures or if
you're just like really good at fluid
animation and like source filmmaker or
something please
let me or him know on twitter or on
discord or on youtube even probably
since there's like a messenger app for
that now we are going to need a ton a
ton of help so if you want to
participate and and collaborate with me
and my good buddy William it'll be very
nice we
very very much appreciate it I think I
think everyone's gonna really like what
it ends up being because most people I
ended up on my channel for a certain
love for a certain thing and this thing
is very heavily related to that thing so
if you don't know what it is already by
now you can probably guess but yeah it's
good oh yeah yeah a Deadpool 20 minute
animated short yeah sure gif totally
that yeah so I think I think we can
probably start wrapping it up it's
getting decently late so and of course
if we keep talking too much Xavier is
probably gonna die so we don't want that
to happen right this broadcast brought
to you by the fine folks G blocks T
blocks is an affordable
subscription-based service that delivers
custom t-shirts straight to your
doorstep with licensed art from Marvel
DC Disney Star Wars Naruto Game of
Thrones Breaking Bad much more you can
get 10% off your first order with the
special promo code Godzilla tbx which is
in the disc which is in the description
you should get some cool t-shirts this
is really cool I got one I showed it it
was cool
so anyway yeah there's that yeah
tune in next time where we will read a
Spidey cool thing no no yes yes no yes
not reading Spidey pool yes we need to